in cold hello
hey there my friendly friday friends
so how do you know when you're living in
a delusion i mean other than joe biden
thinking he's president
i mean when people suddenly believe
something is happening when it really
isn't and then they come after you if
you refuse to play along the left in
this country right now is like that
mentally ill homeless guy screaming at
someone on the sidewalk but there's
actually nobody there but if you tell
him nobody is there he'll attack you for
pointing out the reality of the
situation but with our media such
delusions are rewarded with attention
and therefore incentivized the latest
delusion that florida's parental rights
bill is an attack on gay and trans
people and that somehow merely stating
the distinction between male and female
is an affront to them
but sorry disney according to my data
99.9 of gay and trans aren't offended by
the terms boys and girls where did i get
that statistic where i get all my
biology stats the steam room at the 92nd
street y
but sadly all you need are a few
unhinged voices and control of the
blowhorn and by blowhorn i mean the
mainstream in social media social media
is now the vehicle for delusional
contagions where attention-starved
activists deem words like boys and girls
harmful sorry these people are full of
more than a cage full of chimps with
lactose intolerance
and i know that
but like the bubonic plague it's a
rodent spreading the problem take it
away home of mickey mouse
last summer we removed all of the um
gendered greetings in relationship to
our life skills so we no longer say
ladies and gentlemen boys and girls we
provided training for all of our our
cast members and in relationship to that
so now they know it's hello everyone or
hello friends we we are in the process
of changing over those those recorded
messages and so many of you are probably
familiar when we brought the fireworks
back to the magic kingdom we no longer
say ladies and gentlemen boys and girls
we say dreamers of all ages
dreamers how can you dream when you're
woke
disney once knew the importance of
understanding your audience now they
don't even like their audience it all
sounds like disney is welcoming everyone
with a no girls allowed sign did their
customers ask for it no it's just a
corporation terrified of being unwoke
most families aren't up to speed with
this crap and why because they're too
busy working two jobs so they can put
food on the table for their kids and
maybe one week a year take them to your
stupid theme park and drop a couple
grand
watching a pantless duck speak gibberish
watch out waste management disney's been
making family entertainment for 99 years
but now they're switching to garbage
it's happening in government too while
we face possible war soaring inflation
and rampant crime what's the white house
concerned about they announced that u.s
airport security procedures will become
gender neutral yeah they're going to use
an x for travelers going through
pre-check who don't identify as male or
female
but isn't x the female chromosome
wait till someone complains about that i
just might tsa officers will also
receive new instructions to make
procedures less invasive which is sad
being married i started to enjoy those
pat downs
but of course biden also condemned
dangerous anti-transgender legislative
attacks without
citing actual evidence why we know it's
hard
when there are those out there who don't
see you and don't respect you for
example the onslaught of
anti-transgender state laws attacking
you and your families is simply wrong
this administration is standing up for
you against all these hateful bills and
we're committed to advancing transgender
equality in the classroom on the playing
field at work in our military and our
housing and health care systems
everywhere simply everywhere
yeah well this raises the question why
do democrats only condemn crimes that
aren't happening instead of crimes that
are what about the attacks on elderly
asians or the random murders by homeless
maniacs and liberal-run cities why
doesn't joe care about that
could it be that the people feeding him
this stuff don't care either it's the
will smith slap of politics while we're
talking about this we aren't talking
about the president needing crib notes
to explain why he's trying to trigger
world war iii
so instead let's focus our energy on a
bill that forbids people from talking to
five-year-olds about sex
when we should be asking why they're
fighting to teach indoctrination when
they can't even teach math honestly any
adult that wants to indulge a
five-year-old about sexual issues that
they can't comprehend is the only good
argument for remote learning
delusions become dangerous when your
president buys into it and biden has
just happy to finally be president he's
okay also being a vehicle for idiocy
and finally there's this story a medical
student at the wake forest school of
medicine purposely missed a patient's
vein
because he giggled at the students she
her pronoun pin
coachelle del rosario bragged about it
posting i had a patient i was doing a
blood draw
see my pronoun pin and loudly laughed to
the staff she her well of course it is
what other pronouns even are there it
so i missed his vein so he had to get
stuck twice
well she her sounds like a real
[Laughter]
so there you go corporations government
people all acting irrationally based on
a belief that there's an epidemic of
hostility towards gay and trans it's not
true but sadly what is true
parents may have the science but
activists have the media
let's welcome tonight's guest when she
was behind the podium the media needed
imodium yes
co-host of outnumbered and former white
house press secretary kaylee mcaneeny
he's so british his blood type is earl
grey he's so british he sneezes crumpets
he's so british he sleeps on a
double-decker bus he's so british he
showers in a red phone booth host of the
new show pierce morgan uncensored
premiering april 25th on fox nation
piers morgan thank you yes
and she never uses drugs and is
delightful to work with
april fools [ __ ] his contributor cat tim
right now no never and he'll
he'll give you the shirt off his back if
you need a parachute my massive sidekick
in the nwa's world television champion
tyrus
[Applause]
piers it's like i've seen you almost
every day that's because you have i know
you've been you've been in my dreams in
my studio yeah i don't know where it's
leaving i've been basking in the gut
fell glory ah yes yes the hottest show
person on cable news tv history you can
read it you could just say the hottest
person period
i am beautiful you know this i no doubt
there are people that are anti-trans
transphobic anti-gay but this is a does
this come across to you as a
manufactured outrage uh completely it's
a it's a virus this new virus is where
this very small number of angry
permanently offended
brigade cancel culture propagandists
try and turn everything into something
ending in ick or ist so if you take any
kind of constructive critical approach
to something which is patently
ridiculous immediately you're branded
you're tranphobic you're homophobic
you're racist whatever it may be i got
bounced out of the morning show that i
did in the uk because meghan markle
spewed a bunch of lies to oprah winfrey
about our royal family i said i don't
believe you and was immediately accused
of being racist i didn't believe
somebody who was biracial so this is the
way the world has gone when you look at
this disney fiori in a way it perfectly
encapsulates how mad it all got so
you've got disney who we know stream all
their content to countries where they
behead people for being gay we know that
they are silent about the chinese
oppression of the uyghur muslims but
we're apparently supposed to believe
that they've taken a position a moral
strong position about this issue down in
florida where my god it's so despicable
the governor has decided that kids of
five six seven and eight should not be
exposed to constant propaganda about
their sexuality or genders at a time
when there are now a hundred genders
including apparently astra gender which
is an affinity to the stars and the
planets so why would any parent object
to a teacher teaching them that they can
be astra gender it's all
and the idea that you can raise a
quizzical eye or a concerned brow and
say it's all
without being bounced around being
called a transphobe i support i think
probably most people in this country are
tolerant and compassionate people it
seems like women are the butt of all of
these things it's not really guys it's
just the women right kaylee yeah okay
the woke world is going after women i
mean just think about that that is
happening like you went through the
government they're calling people
pregnant persons yes taking a cue from
aoc apparently i was a menstruating
person not a pregnant woman when i gave
birth to my two-year-old well now
two-year-old um but it's confounding
they have the pregnant male emoji i mean
it's thing after thing after thing it's
erasing women from society and look if
you are an opponent of this bill
basically what you are saying is
kindergarten first grade second grade
third grade your teacher who's
brainwashed by the left probably a lot
of them are gets to teach you about
sexuality no thank you and this man this
president can't keep ron desantis his
name out of his mouth keeps referring to
my former boss as my predecessor and you
know veiled threats at him this guy
needs a foil and that's what this is
about he needs a foil his administration
is collapsing so let's go after
kindergartners yeah what what's your
take on this tyrus well i agree with
them both except for they're missing one
thing that small group they're not that
live in the exterior that's why they
make up crimes that don't that haven't
happened because you can't fact-check
them right they're not going to take the
risk to go down and deal with people who
are actually being assaulted but it's
about fundraising making money has
nothing to do with the transgender
community at all it's just like black
lives matter did the same exact thing
they made it sound like they were there
they were going to help black schools
and poor neighborhoods but they didn't
they loaded up their own
pocketbooks they bought jets and planes
and houses and these same groups are
doing the same thing because then they
will go to the group that they love to
hate the most openly is old white woke
men and women and they'll go tell them
their story and they'll feel terrible
and blame themselves and write huge
amounts of checks so it's a money-making
scheme and so they're never ever going
to actually pick a real situation that
people can look and go well actually
there is more hate crimes against older
asian women right now and women in
general than there is these transgender
things that you're talking about so
they're not going to touch that because
you can argue that and so they're just
doing it until they get the big money
and they get the marches and then you'll
see that they're not helping the poor
transgendered in the inner city who's
afraid to come out because of the
neighborhood they live in they're not
they're not concerned with that but
everyone who's doing it is in a power
play position and that's what this is
really about cat what if the
veterinarian's student purposely missed
the vein of jeans oh yes i knew that
whoa i brought jeans to cats
sorry what if because you she didn't
like your politics and so you bring
jeans in and she purposely misses cheese
hurting me is one thing but herding
chains is another yes
i would be i i wouldn't i wouldn't be
here i would be like launching a
full-scale
attack against this person scorched her
yes because okay someone made fun of you
so you're gonna stab them yes because if
you're missing a vein on purpose that's
not missing a vein that's stabbing yes
the reason you're doing that is to get
the blood or whatever so you're just
stabbing them for no reason and then
things are so crazy that she actually
was like you know what that's something
i can tweet and people will like that
like i stabbed this person who made fun
of me and this wasn't even a trans woman
yeah no this was just but you could be
you could bet she hasn't i bet she has
hashtag be kind in her bio probably
how is this not a hate crime right if if
i stab somebody with her and her and his
or whatever the thing is on their thing
and i said ha because of that and i
stabbed him that's a hate crime right
it's a two-way surprisingly missed a
vein is a lot more words than you need
stabbed she probably has one of those
signs on on the front of her house that
has like all the entire list of all the
things you've seen them everywhere but
apparently i think she's now been
punished she's not allowed to see
patients says in this house we love and
respect jeans
hey sean hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to fox news youtube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else